لو كان لك رأي في قضية صدام،
ما الذي كنت ستقوله للدول المجمعة
على إعدام صدام؟،،
الأمريكان لم يعدموا الزعيم العراقي
إلا بتزكية من بعض الحكام العرب ،
في المقابل جاءت الشعوب لتظهر ردة فعل أخرى ...
فما هي ردود الأفعال لدى الشعوب العربية والعالمية؟
الإجابة كاملة في دقائق هذا الفيديو
لكن قبل أن نجيب على الأسئلة
لا تنسوا الإعجاب بالفيديو والاشتراك بالقناة
وتفعيل الجرس لنستمر بالمزيد إن شاء الله...
..اختلفت ردود الأفعال العالمية
وخصوصا العربية بشأن إعدام الرئيس العراقي السابق صدام حسين.
ونبدأ بطرابلس عاصمة القذافي،
فقد رفض العقيد قرار الإعدام رفضا باتا،
وذكّر الزعماء العرب أن الدور سيأتي إليهم جميعا،
وليس بأيدي الأمريكان وإنما بأيدي شعوبهم،
وهو ما كان، حتى طاله الأمر هو أيضا...
ليبيا أيضا أعلنت الحداد الرسمي على الرئيس العراقي السابق
صدام حسين لمدة ثلاثة..
(وكانت قد اعتبرته أسير حرب)
أما المملكة المغربية فقد تجنبت  التعليق رسميا
على إعدام صدام وسط مظاهرات شعبية منددة،
فيما اكتفت تونس ومصر بالتأسف،
وأقيمت في اليمن صلاة الغائب،
بينما ابتهجت الكويت ومجاميع دينية  في العراق والعالم،
وكسا الحزن مناطق  الفلوجة وتكريت.
وهنا الأردن وفلسطين
فقد شجب غالبية الفلسطينيين والأردنيين
إعدام صدام حسين واعتبروا في لقاءات صحفية
أن ذلك يعد خسارة للأمة العربية وأن إعدامه جاء نتيجة لمواقفه
الرافضة للسياسة الأميركية.
وأما حماس في فلسطين فقد اعتبرت أعدام صدام اغتيالا سياسيا،
وهو ما أكدته باكستان باعتبار الإعدام تفكيكا للمجتمع العراقي
في حين امتنعت اليمن عن الموافقة على الإعدام
فخسرت الدعم الأمريكي الذي يقدر بمئات الملايين،
وأقيمت في المساجد اليمنية صلاة الغائب على روح صدام
في حين أعلن حزب البعث العربي الاشتراكي
عن تقبل التعازي في مجلس "تبريك بالشهادة" ..
وأعرب كثير من الشخصيات السياسية والدينية وشيوخ القبائل  أيضا
عن تضامنهم مع أسرة الرئيس العراقي السابق صدام حسين
وشعب العراق، ووصفوه بأنه شهيد وبأنه "الرئيس الشرعي للجمهورية العراقية".
كما استغربت السودان حكم الإعدام وذكروا أن صدام حسين
لم يخضع لمحاكمة عادلة، واعتبروا أن ذلك كان خروجا
على القانون الدولي والمعايير الأخلاقية الإنسانية
.. أما سويسرا فقد قالت على لسان وزير الخارجية
إنهم أخذوا علما بإعدام الرئيس العراقي السابق
وشددت على أن عقوبة الإعدام "ليست مبررة" بالنسبة لسويسرا...
كما صرح رئيس الوزراء الايطالي السابق
سيلفيو برلوسكوني
بأن اعدام صدام يعتبر خطأ سياسيا وتاريخيا...
بينما المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الأوروبي فقد قال ان الاتحاد الأوروبي
كان يدين الجرائم التى ارتكبها صدام.
ولكن الاتحاد لا يوافق على تنفيذ حكم الإعدام بحقه....
وأما روسيا فقالت أن إعدام صدام سيؤدي إلى تصاعد العنف في العراق...
حتى الفاتيكان مركز المسيحية في العالم،
قد صرح المتحدث باسمها فيديريكو لومباردي،، أن إعدام  صدام حسين خبر مفجع..
بعد تنفيذ الإعدام جاءت ردة فعل من المملكة العربية السعودية
تنتقد توقيت الإعدام، في يوم عيد المسلمين،
لكن إذا كانت قد وافقت على الإعدام
فليس هناك فرق أتم تنفيذه عاجلا أم آجلا،،،
نعم لقد أعدم صدام ووافق غالبية حكام العرب على إعدامه،
لكن الشعوب كان لها رأي آخر،،
فخرجت المظاهرات المنددة بالإعدام في  أغلب الدول العربية
والكثير من الدول الإسلامية حول العالم،،
حتى أن بريطانيا إحدى الدول التي أصدرت الحكم،
قالت أنها ترحب بمحاكمة صدام استنادا الى القانون ولكنها لا تؤيد إعدامه.
وفي الأخير ماذا لو أجمع حكام العرب على رفض قرار إعدام صدام،
هل كانت أمريكا ستتوقف عن تنفيذه؟